heute habe ich meinen Staubsauger mit in
den Garten genommen und das war keine so
gute Idee willkommen zu Tag 4 auf
unserem neuen Bauernhof und es geht
weiter mit dem Make-Over der Gartenhütte
ich habe ja in den letzten Tagen schon
ganz viele Sachen der Vorbesitzer
rausgeräumt die wir nicht mehr brauchen
und jetzt geht's an sauber machen und
weil der Staub beim Fegen immer so
aufwirbelt habe ich mir gedacht hole ich
mir einen Staubsauger dazu aber seht ihr
wie schlecht der sauber macht mich schon
geärgert dass wir nur diesen einen
kleinen popeligen Staubsauger haben und
dann habe ich dieses Biest hier in einer
erscheinen entdeckt das ist ein
Industriestaubsauger das Leben war auf
einmal so schön naja so schön auch
wieder nicht weil ich dann gesehen habe
dass der andere Raum noch voll steht mit
Gerümpel das musste ich also alles
erstmal rausräumen bei jeder einzelne
Sache entscheiden weil mir das Behalten
kommt das weg aber am Ende des Tages war
der Schuppen leer ihr hattet so viele
tolle Ideen was man aus diesem
Gartenschuppen machen kann und im
nächsten Video können wir endlich damit
anfangen